two of the most studied operons are the
trip up Iran and the Lac operon and what
I want to do in this video is focus on
the trip operon which is essential for
the production of tryptophan trip
tryptophan which you might recognize as
an amino acid often associated with
Thanksgiving in turkey dinner but
tryptophan as all or most amino acids
are essential for creating the
polypeptides the proteins that you use
in your body and so the trip up operon
and here we're going to be talking about
not your body what we're going to talk
about something that's in your body
we're going to talk about ecoli it is an
operon that is on the e coli that is
part of the E coli genome and just in
this diagram the way it's drawn it would
be sitting it would be sitting right
over here and just as a reminder an
operon is a combination of a set of
genes as well as the regulatory DNA
sequences for that set of genes in
particular you have the promoter you
have the operator right over here the
promoter is where the RNA polymerase
binds and would start the transcription
process the operator is where repressor
binds and this is going to be essential
for understanding how the trip operon
works and so what are these genes
actually code for well these genes Co
are enzymes that are used in the
construction of tryptophan and I'm
always amazed that enzymes can be used
to construct what what are essentially
molecules that are much smaller than the
enzymes themselves in fact the enzymes
involved are made up of amino acids but
then they're used to make particular
amino acids and so trip e dcba they're
all once they are once they are
transcribed into mRNA and then
translated in the ribosomes these
enzymes are used to create tryptophan
for tryptophan biosynthesis so let's
think about how this works so if we are
in a low tryptophan environment our
ecoli it needs tryptophan it needs that
amino acid is a building block for
it's proteins so in that world it makes
sense at in a low tryptophan environment
the RNA polymerase can just latch on to
the promoter and begin the transcription
process transcribe these these five
genes in into mRNA which then can be
translated into the into those enzymes
and then you will have more tryptophan
biosynthesis that makes sense that you
want to create tryptophan if you're an
environment that does not have a lot of
tryptophan but what if we did have a lot
of tryptophan well if you have a lot of
something around you shouldn't waste
energy creating more of it you have to
appreciate that all organisms that are
around today are the byproducts of
billions of years of evolution and
they've learned to be very careful or
are the ones that are selected for tend
to be the ones that don't waste
resources and so when you have
tryptophan around you probably don't
want this transcription to occur so it
would make sense that maybe tryptophan
can act as a co-repressor for a
repressor molecule for a repressor
enzyme that would attach to the operator
and block the RNA polymerase from
transcribing and that's exactly what
happens so you're in a high tryptophan
environment and tryptophan obviously
does not look like these little yellow
quadrilaterals over there but that's
just for our visualization purposes and
either desire and a polymerase look like
that or neither does the the Terp the
trip receptor repressor look like that
in fact I encourage you to web searches
and see how they actually look there
they're fascinating but when you have a
lot of tryptophan the tryptophan can act
as a co co repressor it can bind to the
trip repressor essentially activate it
so that it'll change its conformation so
then it can then attach to the operator
in the operon and once it's attached to
the operator well then the RNA
polymerase can no longer move forward
with transcription so as you can see
this is a very valuable feedback loop
we're not even necessarily feedback if
you're in an environment with a lot of
tryptophan don't create tryptophan or if
you just have a lot of tryptophan laying
around don't create more tryptophan if
you don't have tryptophan
well then the repressor won't be Co
repressed I guess you can say and then
the tryptophan will actually be created
now tryptophan is an interesting thing
because the control of transcription
isn't the only place where you have some
type of a feedback loop or kind of a
conditional situation you can actually
have direct feedback inhibition between
the proteins and so this part isn't
related to the transcription but if this
is a precursor of tryptophan it's all
very abstract in this diagram and let's
say enzyme one turns into precursor to
enzyme two turns into the precursor 3
and enzyme 3 turns it into tryptophan
well you actually have direct feedback
inhibition where tryptophan can then
bind or interact with enzyme one here
could interact with enzyme one let me do
it in a color you could see could
interact with enzyme one so that it can
no longer act as efficiently taking
precursor one to precursor 2 so this
right over here this is a this is the
classic feedback inhibition feed back in
hish the focus of this video we're
talking about operons and gene
regulation but it's important to realize
that the that the regulation of the
creation of tryptophan doesn't only
occur at the transcription level and I'm
not going to go into this video it's a
slightly more advanced topic but there's
also a regulation of tryptophan
biosynthesis through a process called
attenuation which doesn't affect the
start of transcription but it affects
how things get completed and it will
keep tryptophan from being completely or
the entire process from from going to
completion but the ones that are most
typically talked about are what we just
talked about here where you have your
tryptophan acts as a co repressor of the
trip repressor and also the feedback
inhibition which once again is not
really about gene regulation but you can
see how the product of this process can
go back and inhibit one of the first
enzymes